yeah this show's always been near and
dear to my heart before we talk about it
i do want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
the ridge wallet ridge ball it's a new
smaller sleeker type of wallet that's
designed
for you to be able to ditch your old
bulky wallet pop quiz which one do you
want your pocket
right holds up to 12 cards inside holds
cash on the back a small sleek discreet
fits right in your front pocket so when
you leave the house you can be like keys
phone
wallet ridge ball it comes in over 30
colors including carbon fiber and
titanium and that durability means
lifetime guarantee in fact you can buy
ridge wallet try it out for 45 days if
you don't like it return it full refund
so whether you're looking for a new
wallet and i maintain
father's day is coming up good father's
day gift bring your dad into the 21st
century have him ditch his old wallet
just click the link below go to
ridge.com
john's enter promo code john save
yourself 10 off your ridge wallet and
thank you once again to ridgewallet for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now we're
going to talk about the show the return
of the show that you know i love whether
you want to call it my guilty pleasure
show
devilishly good time show or just the
tom ellis show
point is lucifer's back in season five
part two
which is a fancy way of saying six i
feel like lucifer's back and at the end
of season five part
one god showed up god showed up during
lucifer and michael and minadel's big
throw down angels are fighting
god shows up the season ended now we
pick up where
dennis haysbert is the one who plays god
he's got lessons to give
and to get dennis haysbert is perfect as
god because i'm pretty sure
president david palmer uh was in fact
god so the gist of this season actually
i'm going to give you a spoiler warning
we'll talk about some spoilers stuff not
going to be a play-by-play but you know
going to talk about some spoiler-ish
stuff spoiler warning you've been warned
but the gist of this season is god is
retiring
so there has to be a successor and to
the struggle it really is like lucifer
and michael are both like
i should be it and the thing that stands
out in this season is the fact that
all the side characters shine they've
always shined i've always loved the side
characters in this show every side
character has
either a large moment and generally
speaking an episode dedicated to them
it's not a show where it's like yeah the
title character is all you care about
though
he does stand out now rachel harris is
linda martin she's always been a
standout in the show
amy garcia's ella lopez has always been
one of my favorites i think at this
point
is probably in large part to the fact
that she's the one who doesn't know that
lucifer
is actually the devil she doesn't know
that lucifer is a devil she doesn't know
when minadile's
and angels she doesn't know that god is
here that was one of the things that
made linda martin
stand out for a large section of this
show is she was the one who knew
she was the one who knew we were dealing
with celestial beings she was burdened
with that knowledge now other than linda
dan knows chloe knows everybody knows
except for ella lopez that her adorable
sweet natured
optimism she's one of my favorite
characters though with that adorableness
i guess they're in this season they were
like hey she also has
dexter morgan tendencies or something
whenever she sees a crime scene she's
like
more blood which is kind of in conflict
with the show's
own lore because she's like oh i'm i
feel so guilty
about these thoughts i have when i see
an accident or i see a crime scene so
the show says hey
she feels this guilt you can tell she's
a good person also in the show if you
feel guilt you go to hell as seen in the
fact that dan died and i thought that
was
they [ __ ] dan over then when it
happened i was like okay well
it's a show dealing with celestials so
there's always that sense of
oh they died but they're in a better
place you know they live
on except in lucifer's lore in the
show's lore
it's your guilt that sends you to hell
dan had guilt with him so i guess he
didn't go to heaven when he died it's
just still like that laura i was like
really i feel like hell would be filled
with all sorts of good people that feel
guilty or at the very least people with
anxiety they're like i just feel guilty
because i have anxiety
i guess i'm in hell and heaven would be
filled with a bunch of [ __ ] bags who
feel no guilt because
you know shitbags but when lucifer went
to heaven to get chloe there was that
guy who was like hey i was in hell and i
learned my way out of hell
and i evolved and i learned my lessons
so
they're probably gonna do that with dan
now that they've established people can
get out of hell still
left a bad taste in my mouth damn's a
good dude like the show didn't always
know what to do with dan
other than well he's the ex and that
that was his character for a bit i don't
know dan cracked me up and that whole
episode that was basically one big prank
that
lucifer did to him at first i was like
oh this is a big episodic
romp okay but i ended up really liking
it by the end of that episode but in a
world where the first half of the season
and the second half of this season or
the first half of the second half of the
season
so i guess basically the second quarter
of the the third fourth and the fourth
fourth of the entire season but the
first half in the second half
of this half of the season is divided
into two themes the second theme being
okay well
lucifer he's gonna take over as god
because
better him than michael because
michael's a dick i've always liked the
fact that this show plays up the fact
that
history's written by the victors but it
was the first half of this block of the
story
that's what i liked the whole thing
about god
and lucifer god and his kids making
amends the whole theme was about
parenthood the inevitable fact that
parents [ __ ] up the whole show of
lucifer is about growth you know it's
the devil learning
to be more than the hedonistic devil
that he has been
and that growth is seen from god in a
world where the books are always better
if you look at the biblical stories you
got like
old testament god he was pissed at
everything fire and
so oh hey you looked back at the
explosions you looked back
at the enormous noise of destruction
going on behind you
such an enormous audible sound of
earth-shattering
[ __ ] that you could only be compelled
to turn around be like
what is that gotta turn into a pillar of
salt because you know old testament
style and the new testament god's like
you know what puppies and rainbows and
hugs and kittens so growth among god is
is there among the pages i liked how the
show went about it because
the inevitable fact is parents [ __ ] up
i remember when my parents were my age
actually i remember when my parents were
younger than i
am now i remember thinking like well
they have all the answers
they are something else they're on
another level how's the phrase uh
mother is the name of god on the lips
and hearts of children i believe that's
how eric draven and the crow said it if
i'm misquoting apologies
been a long day but now i'm looking back
like dude they didn't know
what the [ __ ] they were doing they had
no idea they were making it up as they
went along
so the first half of the season was all
about parenting and the mistakes parents
have made
and the damage that the kids carry with
them because of it and just letting that
go and the parents going yeah
i'd have done things differently if i
could do it over again like said every
parent ever
and if you look at the ultimate parent
kid squabble that's gotta be god and the
devil right so it was cool
seeing them on screen bury the hatchet i
just thought that it was sweet it was
endearing
it was really smart i like seeing god
being this vulnerable dad
apologizing to his kids being like i
made some mistakes also this season when
god came had an
era of fun to it you know every time god
shows up somewhere everyone just breaks
into song and dance musical numbers
which i feel like they got
such good reception from that scene when
lucifer is dancing to kenny loggins i'm
all right it was a great scene and at
first i was like ah they're overcooking
it a little bit and i was like
dude you can't take this show too
seriously
just just let it ride and i sat back and
i actually
ended up having a good time with it not
just because of mazzakin's
bad to the bone sequence which is the
stuff that dreams are made of but
there's actually a story-based reason
for it it's like god's
kind of losing it and that's why he
needs to retire in the end i felt like
the last episode was rushing to the end
and i was like oh that's an abrupt
ending because i had heard this was
gonna be the last season
and i will say it felt like that
everything that was happening i was like
this is series finale [ __ ] happening it
is coming to a head come to find out
season six like actual season six
is apparently happening which shocked me
the fact that it felt like a series
finale before i knew that which this
late
in the lucifer game it should feel that
way so i was glad it did so season five
part two i really enjoyed i'm a big
softie
at this point in my life you all know
that by now but i love dennis haysbert
as god i buy him as this
omnipotent omniscient figure but also
vulnerable dad and i loved seeing this
dad god
and his estranged son work it out you
bring those themes tom ellis charm
illustrating a charismatic lead
character that
isn't as all evil villainous as we've
heard compelling and interesting support
characters and that's why i just
i love this show alright so lucifer
season five part two have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you